jetzt kommt die krönung jetzt müsst ihr
sagen wer wird das dschungelcamp
gewinnen wenn wir
schon dschungel orakel befragt und so
bist du da ich gerne weil ich bin davon
fest überzeugt dass es brigitte oder
brigitte nielsen werden wird weil ich
immer positiv die so hart gesotten die
ist wirklich wirklich mit allen wassern
gewaschen die hat es mit flavor flav mit
sylvester stallone ausgehalten dann wird
sie das ein paar kakerlaken und wie
beistehen also ich glaube die wird auf
jeden fall junge queen ok und damit der
meinung ja
normalerweise glaube ich immer dass
junge könig oder königin würde der sich
so ein bisschen
zurückhält und so müssen die auffällige
und soja verständnis für alle hat aber
ribéry sieht vereint ganz ganz viele
eigenschaften sich die ist endlich eine
ehemalige sex bombe oder immer noch für
manche leute und die jetzt wie gesagt
schon ausdauer bewiesen bei anderen
sachen und ich glaube auch dass die not
war auch so ein bisschen
mutti sein kann für alle also notfalls
kann man sich da auch so anlehnen schon
lange ich durch einige trash formate im
fernsehen gehört auf den fall erfahren
und weiß wie man glaube ich den
zuschauer daheim irgendwie die anrufe
entlockt ich glaube dass das hat die
bestimmt ganz ganz gut drauf was für
befürchtung ich bei ihr aber die hat
sich ja komplett runderneuert lassen
aufhörst fernsehen ob das unter diesen
natürlichen bedingungen alles hält das
bleibt abzuwarten bleibt dran im
dschungel gehälter halten die titel von
der brigitte